- I love your intro though,
turning around with a computer.
- I know, right. now.
Hello.
- Well, hello there.
(calm music)
So welcome everyone.
My name is Terrell Gibson and I'm here to
welcome my friend, my colleague
and now my peer in the Academy,
Shannon Baker Davis.
- Hello, I am Shannon Baker Davis.
I'm a picture editor.
Yeah, I'm just happy to be here.
- I mean, I know you've
come up in a similar way
that I came up, which is like old school
there were no shortcuts whatsoever.
You know, we started
from the very beginning
and built a body of work and
got to a certain position
and then had to kind of
reboot and start over
and work on some smaller projects again.
Cut your rate in half, try to build it up
and you're constantly in that reset.
And then you get to a
moment like this, right,
where you realize decades later
that all of that has kind
of like come to fruition
and really paid off.
So it's really good to
kind of like step back
and outside of yourself every
now and then and just realize,
wow this was an incredible journey.
This is an incredible journey.
I certainly as a kid from New Jersey
with no connections to the
film business whatsoever,
didn't have that sort of,
I guess you would say just that,
they say you have to see it to be it.
I never saw it, you know what I mean?
Started working in New York,
never ran into another
person that looked like me
in that period of time.
But slowly but surely you realize
we all are out there, you know?
- Yeah, I'm the same way.
I grew up in Augusta, Georgia.
My mom is a nuclear chemist
and my dad as an electrical engineer
and I was like, I wanna do movies.
And they're like, well,
how are you gonna do that?
Like we don't know anything about that.
You can't do that.
So you have to have an extra bit of drive
when you don't have anybody in your world
that is experienced working up the ranks
or been handed a job or has a relative,
a parent that already
works in the industry.
And I'm still amazed that I
get to do this for a career
and I get to do this to make money
and like no matter like
when I am up till 2:00 AM
or I've gotten another round
of notes and I'm complaining,
like the moment that someone
says well what do you do
and you tell them and then they're like,
oh my God, that's so amazing.
And you're like, I guess
it is kind of amazing,
and it just makes you remember
that you were that person that just
like glamorized this whole business.
And no matter how it
may trouble you at times
you still, I still I'm
so proud to be an editor
and proud to work on feature films
and work with some of the people
that I've worked with over the years,
like it's still amazing to me.
- So I kept running back in my mind
how you might respond to me
asking you for a drink after.
- So that was you asking me?
That was elaborate.
- In my mind it wasn't that forward,
you know what I mean?
It was more smoother than that.
- I was supposed to call you I thought.
- Yeah, you were supposed to,
but you didn't.
- So yeah, talk to us a little bit more
about that in terms of your arc
in terms of starting reality
and then getting into
scripted and then featured.
- Yeah, so I graduated from AFI in 2003
and there were not a lot of jobs
in scripted when I came out.
There weren't, there was no Netflix,
there were no streaming platforms,
it was like you worked on Law and Order
or you worked on some sitcom.
And so I moved back to the East coast
and got a job on a HGTV show
and I was happy to assist,
but I always knew I wanted to cut.
And so I just kept with that
because I had narrative like education.
I had a narrative filmmaking education
and that helped me a lot in reality TV
because we were constructing the story.
We were taking footage that was
and it was similar to
documentary filmmaking
where they shot over a long period of time
and the editors had to figure
out what the story was.
I did that for 10 years and
worked on shows that won Emmy's,
but I decided I really
wanted to do narrative
and so I moved back to LA.
Two friends were directing
an independent feature
and we had been talking about
me at editing it for years
and they finally got the money
together and they were like
we understand if you don't feel ready,
but I was like this is now or never.
So I cut that independent
feature and loved it so much
and I was like, this is it,
this is what I have to do.
Networking and trying to, you know,
and sending out cold
emails and doing a lot,
meeting with people and Katie Skirping
who was on the Good Wife
and she had been the
assistant on the Good Wife
for six seasons and
she was being bumped up
for the seventh season, the last season.
And she was like, I feel like I,
she's like I can't hire you now,
they won't let me hire someone so green
because I am a new editor.
She's like, but let's stay in touch.
And we stayed in touch.
And then at one point during the season
the assistant editor that she had hired
had to leave and she said,
she called me on like a
Friday and she was like,
can you come on Monday?
And I said, I'm there.
And it worked out like
I assisted that show
and then I assisted Jamie Nelson
on the first season of Insecure.
Then I assisted Ferrell Levy,
who was my professor at AFI.
And then I talked my way into
an editing job on a new series for BET.
And all the while I was
cutting independent features,
cutting shorts, just
cutting anything I could
that was narrative.
That's the way I got to
cut The Weekend with Stella
and that just like catapulted my career
cuz we got into Toronto
and it was in the theater
and then we did The Photograph together.
And once you do a film that either does
really well at the festivals
or gets picked up by a studio,
gets picked up by a streamer,
it's like that is then you
have your name is on lists
and it just becomes a little bit easier.
- Oh yeah, Spin Doctors, classic.
Tim, I wanna chop it up more,
but I gotta get to my squash game.
Was that Visa or MasterCard?
(hands slappings)
(upbeat music)
- There's an element of
persistence when you're an editor.
I would say that about being an editor
you can't be a quitter.
You have to be the one person that's like
everybody quit around me,
but I'm gonna go sit in my avid
and I'm gonna get this thing done.
Like I'm gonna be that person.
And I would just encourage,
if that's not how you
feel about something,
then probably there's
something else for you.
There's something else,
there's something for everyone.
But there are certain
aspects of a personality
that an editor just has to have and feel
and want to have in themselves.
So that's why I say persistence.
- Every day you get in to
ask yourself the question
when you leave did I make it better today?
And then the accumulation
hopefully of months and months of
really putting the screws to it,
hopefully you end up on the other side
with something that everybody's proud of,
so I'd say that and
particularly African-American
young aspiring editors.
Cuz when I came up I knew
of literally two maybe
and I might be,
that might be,
I might be padding that by one.
But Jess, if you see the two of us
and you're watching this right now,
understand that if we've made it this far,
certainly you can too.
So keep working, keep working.
- Of course.
- Yeah.
- And I always hope that
like we both talked about
how long it took to get to where we are
and I always hope that it'll
be easier for the next person.
I always hope that whatever I do
that I impressed enough
people that they'll be like,
oh we gave this young Black woman a shot,
I'm not gonna be so afraid to do it again.
Really be able to feel free to
have an opinion about things
and walk into the room
and know that you know what you're doing.
And yeah I always hope that
it'll be a little bit easier
and there'll be like three
or four people next year
or in a couple years
that are being invited
into the Academy that are people of color
or women or women of color.